[Music]
[Applause]
is here obi-wan Kenobi what makes you
think so trauma and the frosh last time
I felt it it was in the presence of my
old master if you're right he must not
be allowed to escape ah
escape is not his plan I must face him
alone be too proud of this technological
terror you've constructed the ability to
destroy a planet is insignificant next
to the power of the force it says I'm
supposed to raise my finger and strangle
him with with the force what did what is
that about oh well there's this magical
entity called the force and it actually
is well forceful and it strangles the
person with just your fingers that's gay
I just have a gun um give me a fucking
gun okay we'll look into that will
stupid twat strangling him with my
imagination sort of shitty film is this
she lied she lied to us
she'd never consciously betray the
rebellion what she needs is a good
shagging by yours truly um that is not
in the script oh it should be don't I
get to love scene somewhere twat I've
been waiting for you all be one we meet
again at last the circle is now complete
when I left you I was but the learner
now I am the master only the master of
evil Darth you're damn straight
now let's shag that is not in the script
either can't I shag anything in this
movie can shag a lightsaber that sounds
strangely pleasurable those
transmissions you intercepted what have
you done with those plans we intercepted
no transmissions this is the counselor
ship we're on a diplomatic mission if
this is a consular ship where's the
ambassador
come on I'm downtown this ship apart -
do you find those plans and bring me all
the passengers I want them alive in
shaggable mr. Connery right she's a
princess I'm a double agent you're not a
double agent you're the I should be can
we put that in the script no you why not
the dark ruler of the universe you don't
go around shagging people you know what
I may be a hundred and age but I was
still voted People magazine's most
sexiest man in the US you just shut
eject watt and can you stop calling me a
twat all right you fuckin haggis
yeah powers are weak old man but you
can't even get it up anymore but I I
shagged your mother you did not shag his
mother of course I did
I'm the Dark Lord of the galaxy that's
what I do shag mothers what what is your
obsession I'm just really cure what is
your obsession with shagging I'd like to
get some very honest sensitive man this
will be a day long remembered
it has Sheen the end of Kenobi it will
soon see the end of the rebellion
martinis for everyone shaken not forced
see what I did there
I made it all hip to the movie by
calling it forced yes yes I could have
said Stern you didn't smarter be quiet
you I was shooting people and fucking
your mother while you were still in
diapers one surprised me that's what
your mother said and now your highness
we will discuss the location of your
hidden rebel base in your pants stop it
just stop it stick to the script
stop I'm making the film better no you
are not you are making it worse this is
already a very hard film to cast even
comprehend no not gonna see this shit
I'm attic space Turkey if there isn't
some good shagging and you know what I
want that theme to every time a
spaceship flash on I want to hear da da
da da da da da da we already have this
very nice music john williams's work out
what the fuck is that he's very well
known yes this wonderful theme it goes
dah dah dah dah dah dah
wait wait wait I can work with that hold
on da da da da da da da da da da da da
don't act so surprised your highness
you won't tell any mercy mission this
time several transmissions were beamed
aboard this ship by rebel spies I want
to know what happened to the plans they
sent you and if they ended up in your
pants I don't know what you're talking
about I I think you do know what you're
talking about you're talking about your
pants stick to the part that says Darth
Vader you read that very simple she okay
pick up that red pen there you see that
red pen yes now I want you to take this
line okay now cross that out and replace
the final words within your pants no I'm
not doing that yes you need to do that
no I am NOT doing who is directing this
picture not you oh I beg to differ
laddie
who are you where did you come from I'm
double I'll fucking seven that's who I
am now get me a martini shaken not
stirred
you mean force no I mean stud forced was
gay I have spoken you are part of a
Rebel Alliance and a traitor
take her away to my bedroom I what did
you write that in the script mr. Connery
no which it's right here
it's written in red ink well I suggest
you talk to your copy editor sounds like
one of their mistakes I'm only reading
what is in this script now can you
please hand me that red pen back No
these fighters have broken off from the
main group come with me
I said come well thank you so much mr.
Connery for coming in I have to be
honest we probably will not be choosing
you for this part we have another person
by the name of James Earl Jones Jim
Jones who the hell is that
he's a very talented actor
african-american actor one of the finest
and we are very very proud he's not
going anywhere you should stick with me
well to be frank you're a very um
violent and abusive and downright mean
Joe my best qualities I mean granted we
love that in a villain we just don't
love it in a actor we don't think it
it's called method acting I have to
inhabit the role which means if I wanted
to strangle you with the gay little
force thing I could right now you see
what I'm doing I'm holding my fingers up
I see that and as you can notice I am
NOT gasping for air I am I hope you're
not joking to death on your own
incompetent well I'll tell you what why
don't you wave your fingers outside that
would be the most helpful for us right
now
but I'd prefer to be in here I know you
would but we prefer for you to be
outside but you can't do bad time living
here
didn't you see the sleeping bag in the
corner yeah I want to question you about
that what is that about I'm living here
why are you living here mr. Connery
because I have no other job that and I'm
sleeping with your secretary get out
[Music]
[Applause]
the stew Highlander - then that'll be a
success